Hello everyone
, this is Nakayama, the director of Street Fighter 6. Street Fighter 6 was announced in June, and
thank you for the many responses.
tan
Now there's only
seasar jan
Is it
slow or wing
?
That's
right, the view position that looks at the specs more than rde
voodoo The
condition is
par It's been
about 4 days poni
ah ah ah ah I
'm fine
[Applause] Yes
[music]
No I'm going
to wash the file
Start ah ah ah ah
How was it?  Uka Street
Fighter 6 has
three main modes: World Tour Fighting Ground Battle Hanyu.
First of all, it's Dhalsim, a master of Western paintings.It's a character who attacks tricky
by manipulating a long reach and a flame technique even when moving at the speed of
sound.The chest accessories and costumes have a new
design.
That's right, we
'll fight with our weapons of dynamic strength and star power
Etro City Smart
It seems that we have opened the Sumo Chaya Edmon, a store where you can enjoy
chanko nabe.  A new costume has been prepared for him, who is moving.
Area reloading that attacks from the air
has been added
.
It is said that there will be a big change in appearance, but
what kind of story is there?
Nisasa has also learned and expanded the range of fighting
. In
Street Fighter 6, there are many new
characters and familiar
characters in the series
.
I think there was a scene.This
is a new fighting content called Extreme
Battle.You can fight by combining the rules that determine victory and defeat with
the banks that appear in tizen
.
For
example, you can select a bomb gimmick to fight.It will
be a battle with unique rules, so
I think you will be able to experience a different experience
than
usual.There are various other things in the fighting round.
Next is new information about the automatic commentary function.
Please take a look at the video that these people agreed with for the Japanese commentary this time.
I'll buy
the name Birdseye is gaining power
Hard state drive oha This place
is different in the back
n
ame I can live with my daughter living in Takano
[Laughter]
Let's see what's called this lineage
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa!!!
I
'm looking forward to the future battles See
you later Kousuke Hirai, who is known as a
good sportscaster to the commentators, participated in the match
.
Thank you I am
a veteran who has been watching sumo wrestling for over 300 years
.
Please look forward to future announcements
The main character will meet various awards and
become stronger through street competition
What kind of events will you learn from?
You can enjoy your own story in this world
.  Development experience
Ehime Mishopon Masun
Not
only petitions and body shape, but also muscle mass and
meticulous attention to
detail.  By doing so,
the player's individuality can be displayed
more.In addition to the appearance, the
character's performance can be changed by equipping it.If
you want to start with punishment, start
from the street.
It is
possible to
immediately battle in various locations
, and the Yin and Yang battles and galleries will also gather
.
Of course, you can also use it with lights, but you
can rely on that skill when
you move around the city or when you
explore.  The
world tour, including obtaining items and customizing, is a
completely new mode in which you can enter the world of Street
Fighter and experience the
world of Street Fighter.  It
will
be a place where you can enjoy a variety of games and communication while connecting with
others.You can easily enjoy the battle have much as soon as you sit in the battle cabinet.It feels
like
you are in an arcade.
You can also participate
Various items are available at the shop
Customize your avatar and have fun
You can also play nostalgic titles on the game cabinets
in the arcade Please look forward to what titles you can play
[Music]
Liven up the venue with a dj booth
It's also possible to take pictures at photo spots.We've
included a lot of fun elements.We're
developing the Battle Hub space as a place that everyone wants to visit every day.Please
look
forward to
it.Lastly here  Please see the video of
ng no go nail de sevibar zero
3 birdie
nanairo hair growth tano day
can you do
You can
participate You can experience the Battle Hug I introduced today The
number of participants is limited, so
please check the schedule and application details on the official Street Fighter 6 website.
We are planning to release the latest information on Street Fighter 6. In
addition, the
special program Street
Fighter 6 special program will
be held from 24:00 on Friday, the 16th of the month Japan time tomorrow
.
Please don't miss it